chaos isn't a pit chaos is a ladder hey
youtubers it's Charlie and it's time for
my Game of Thrones Season 4 preview for
Littlefinger or as I like to think of
him the family guy Herbert of King's
Landing raise your hand if you just made
the Herbert sound in your head whenever
I said that one more time here's the
mild spoiler warning for everything from
seasons one two three one of the really
awesome things about Littlefinger is is
that he's all about intrigue on the show
whereas a lot of characters like Jaime
deal with bran and muscles Littlefinger
really has to rely on his wits you get
the impression though that he's just not
quite as good as varies though with the
exception of season three or he might
just be a psychopath because of a new
season forecasting announcement for a
character that kind of has something to
do with Lysa Arryn in the Vale I'm
guessing that Littlefinger is actually
going to be spending a lot of time there
remember at the end of season three he
basically agreed to become her suitor so
that he could get Oliver wealth I don't
think he'll be going to the Vale till
about halfway through the season there's
a bit of a spoiler event that happens in
King's Landing I won't talk about it too
much here he'll also spend a lot of time
in season for continuing to creep on
Sansa
Herbert style there you just made the
Herbert sound again didn't you
one of the really awesome things about
george RR martin is is that he also is
really good at paying off stories so I'm
guessing season four will pay off a lot
of storylines that were set up in
seasons 1 as well as things that happen
before the show started Littlefinger is
a big part of a lot of those storylines
especially some of the major events from
season 1 remember he used to be the
master of coin that's basically like the
accountant for the king he basically
helped push the crown into debt and what
that does is is it really destabilizes
the government leaving it really
vulnerable to a takeover from outside
force like Danny and her army of dragons
or even the Martel's who are a big
presence in season 4 and going forward
so a little finger hasn't really been
waging so much of a physical war like
all of the other characters
he's been waging more of a financial war
which is just another way to crumble the
government without the use of soldiers
remember it during season 3 varies
basically told us that Littlefinger
would rather rule over the ashes well in
season 4 we'll learn more about some of
the things that he's done to further
that agenda so because Santa's character
is so tied up in Littlefinger's
character in season 4 and going forward
I'll be doing her video next that'll
post on Friday be sure to subscribe to
get it as always be sure to let me know
which characters you want to talk about
first I'll add them to the top of my
list my next video after that we'll be
posting on
Monday if you really want to help me out
please like and share this video you can
click here to get all my other Game of
Thrones Season 4 videos that I've done
so far and you can click here to learn
all about my new attack on Titan and
welcome to night Vale marathon thank you
so much for watching high fives you guys
are awesome